Dr Weiss, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir, Patrice.
- On vous invite à des moments
charnières parce que, là,
M. Legault dit : "Après Noël,
on peut songer, si les enfants
se font bien vacciner comme
prévu, on peut songer à laisser
tomber une après les autres
les mesures : distanciation,
masque, etc." Est-ce que
vous êtes, est-ce que
vous arrivez à la même
conclusion dans vos analyses?
Dr KARL WEISS, président, Asso.
des médecins microbiologistes
- Bien, moi, je pense qu'il y a
des mesures qu'on ne laissera
jamais tomber jusqu'à un certain
point. Par exemple, dans les
hôpitaux, le fait de porter
un masque continuellement
a un impact majeur sur la
transmission de beaucoup
de virus qui ne sont pas
la COVID aux patients,
au personnel etc. Il y a
des avantages à garder certaines
mesures dans le milieu
de la santé. Le mois de janvier,
il ne faut pas oublier, puis là,
c'est la pleine période
de la saison respiratoire.
Ce qu'on sait de l'hémisphère
sud, c'est qu'on risque d'avoir
une petite année d'influenza,
mais on sait jamais.
Par contre, on a beaucoup
de virus qu'on appelle des virus
respiratoires. L'autre chose
que ça nous dit, ça nous dit
qu'on est prêts maintenant
à accepter de vivre non plus
avec une pandémie, mais avec une
endémie, c'est-à-dire
avec un virus qui reste là
de façon persistante, parfois
qu'il va augmenter en termes
de nombre, on va avoir
des éclosions ici et là, et que
donc il va falloir composer
avec une vie normale, mais
en acceptant continuellement
d'avoir un certain nombre
de cas, d'avoir un certain
nombre de patients hospitalisés,
et dépendamment de la situation,
comme pour la grippe de fermer
ou d'ouvrir des vagues. Donc,
la loi des mesures d'urgence,
c'est un contexte légal, ce
n'est pas un légal de science.
Ça peut avoir des implications,
et je ne suis certainement pas
juriste pour discuter des
implications de l'aspect légal
de cette loi, mais la science
en tant que tel, de dire que
par exemple, l'intérieur des
transports en commun en plein
hiver, si les gens sont habitués
à porter des masques, ça peut
avoir un effet bénéfique, comme
on le voit dans beaucoup de pays
asiatiques, de garder l'aspect
du lavage des mains, c'est très
bien. Je pense qu'on va hériter
des mesures de la COVID qui vont
persister, qui vont rester, mais
pour le bien de beaucoup
d'autres choses qui ne seront
plus de la COVID. Donc, c'est
deux choses, à mon sens,
qui sont séparées.
- On verra, vous dites,
inévitablement plus de masques
dans nos vies au cours des
prochaines années qu'on en
voyait ici. Mais la question,
c'est est-ce que ce sera
obligatoire pour entrer
dans un magasin par exemple?
Est-ce qu'on ne va pas en
janvier, février, mars, arriver
à un moment où ce ne sera
plus obligatoire?
- Ça va être une décision qui va
être une décision politique
et on verra à ce moment
la situation épidémiologique
de la COVID au Québec.
On verra aussi la situation
épidémiologique des autres virus
parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
que l'an dernier, on a eu
une année avec 0, je dis bien
0 cas d'influença, donc de
grippe, parce que bien sûr, la
COVID a pris toute la place,
mais parce qu'aussi, on a mis
toutes sortes de mesures en
place. Il n'y a pas eu
de transmission. Cette année,
il y a le retour à l'école.
On a ouvert la société, ce qui
est très bien, mais dans ce
contexte-là, on veut pas non
plus avoir des infections,
de transmission de virus.
Il ne faut pas oublier que
l'influenza, la principale
conséquence, c'est une
conséquence économique.
C'est-à-dire que quand vous avez
beaucoup de grippe dans une
société, les enfants tombent
malade : ils ne vont pas
à l'école. Les parents restent
à la maison pour s'occuper
des enfants : ils ne vont pas
travailler. Il y a des
conséquences économiques à ça.
Si le masque peut permettre
de contrôler ce genre de choses,
pourquoi pas comme outil
de contrôle et non pas comme
outil législatif ou quoi que
ce soit du genre.
- Oui, dans certains contextes
mais Dr Weiss, il y a fort
longtemps, ça nous paraît il y a
mille ans, mais vous m'aviez dit
que ça va prendre deux ans à peu
près, d'ailleurs, vous étiez pas
mal clairvoyant parce qu'on est
rendus là, 20 mois plus tard.
Il faudra vivre avec le risque,
le risque zéro n'existe pas.
Pour aller, je sais pas...
Nous, au bureau, on a le masque.
Dès que je sors du plateau, etc.
Est-ce que vous voyez quand même
retour à une certaine normalité
pour ce symbole qui est
devenu... oui dans les hôpitaux,
oui dans les transports en
commun, je vous entends,
mais par ailleurs, on pourra
libérer un peu, non?
- Tout à fait, mais il y aura
une condition aussi : c'est
d'essayer de vacciner rapidement
la population à risque.
Supposons qu'au mois de janvier,
on dit que la situation est
tellement bonne au Québec qu'on
enlève les masques, par exemple,
dans les centres d'achat ou dans
les endroits intérieurs publics
où il y a beaucoup de monde.
Vous allez avoir des gens de la
population de plus de 65 ans
qui auraient été vaccinés
il y a plus de six mois, qui
deviendraient un peu plus
vulnérables à rattraper
la COVID. Peut-être pas très
malades, peut-être qu'ils
n'iront pas à l'hôpital,
mais ils risquent quand même
d'être positifs de temps en
temps. Ce que ça veut dire,
ça veut dire qu'un moment donné,
il faudra avoir aussi une
stratégie, qui est souvent
une stratégie multiple. On l'a
dit : c'est un agrégat de
mesures qui nous permet
de contrôler la COVID. C'est
la vaccination en premier lieu,
le masque, le lavage des mains
et la distanciation, donc c'est
un ensemble de facteurs.
Ça a eu un impact positif sur
les autres virus respiratoires
et oui...
- J'ai l'impression, vous êtes
médecin, c'est normal, comme
ça a eu des effets positifs
sur les autres virus et tout ça,
vous dites comme médecin :
continuons comme ça, mais en
même temps, il y a d'autres
aspects qui sont, et ce n'est
pas idéal de porter la masque
dans plusieurs circonstances.
- Tout à fait. Je ne veux pas du
tout envoyer le message qu'on va
devenir une société masquée
et enfermée. Pas du tout.
Au contraire. Je dis qu'on est
retourné à une société beaucoup
plus améliorée aujourd'hui que
ce qu'on était il y a six mois
et encore bien mieux de ce qu'on
était il y a un an. On est
revenu au Québec avec
une société pas mal ouverte;
on est retourné à l'école
et aux universités. Les gens
sont retourner travailler, etc.
J'espère qu'on sera capable
d'enlever quasiment toutes
les mesures à un moment donné.
Mais il va rester avec une
certaine endémiecité de ce virus
qui va faire qu'on va devoir
vivre avec, et gérer le virus.
Et dans certains environnements,
entre autres le milieu
hospitalier, le milieu
de la santé, les CHLSD,
il va falloir probablement
garder le masque.
- Dr Weiss, les enfants.
Expliquez-moi pourquoi... parce
qu'on sent beaucoup de craintes
chez les parents autant
les parents qui sont allés
se faire vacciner qui se disent
: ma petite de 7 ans, le petit
bras, pourquoi c'est important
de vacciner les enfants de 5-11
ans d'après vous?
- Souvent, c'est la catégorie
actuellement qui transmet,
qui a beaucoup de cas
proportionnellement à ce qui est
présent dans la population.
C'est tout à fait normal.
Si on veut retourner à une vie
encore plus normale, c'est un
autre bassin de la population
qu'il faut toucher en termes
de vaccination pour réduire
l'impact du virus sur la
population québécoise, en
général. Les enfants, je vous
donne un exemple, imaginez que
vous ne vaccinez pas les enfants
que vous êtes travailleur
de la santé ou quelqu'un qui
travaille, qui est doublement
vacciné, et que vous avez un
enfant qui est positif à la
COVID. On vous teste, vous
testez positif, mais vous n'êtes
pas très malade. Ce n'est plus
une question que vous soyez très
malade, mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait? Est-ce que vous laisse
retourner travailler? Est-ce
qu'on vous dit d'attendre
quelques jours à la maison?
Cela aura des impacts
économiques et toutes sortes
d'impacts d'autres façons.
Encore là, c'est encore un outil
supplémentaire, pas absolu,
il n'y a pas...
- Docteur, vous êtes à l'aise
avec ça? Vous, si vous aviez des
jeunes enfants, vous êtes à
l'aise?
- Tout à fait. Vous savez,
mes enfants ont été vaccinés
dès qu'ils ont pu être vaccinés.
Donc ça a très rapide. Il n'y
pas eu de problème.
- Très bien. Dr Weiss, c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous
parler. Merci beaucoup, à très
bientôt.
- Au r